so Joe it's lovely to see you here at
the premiere for the raid - now of
course we know you're involved in the
raid the first movie as well so how did
it confer be involved in this on
composing for it it was a completely
different process because I'm not sure
if you know that Mike and I scored the
American version and fired Ron Oggy who
are behind me scored the Indonesian
version and for this version Gareth
really liked some of the elements of
each score so he put me together with
Fajar nogi unfortunately mike is busy
working on his Lincoln Park album so he
couldn't join us but this one has been a
really interesting process working with
composers who are based in Indonesia I'm
based in LA so it's really learning
process for all of us they will have you
learnt doing that and more the kind of
challenges you face along the way well
it's great when you're in LA you know
working on Hollywood movies you kind of
I wouldn't say get into a rut but you
kind of get into a mindset where you say
this is how we do something this is how
we're gonna score this this is how we're
going to work on this film is how we
approach this scene when you bring in
someone who's completely outside of that
realm it really opens up the
possibilities and same for them for them
they've never worked in LA they've never
worked in Hollywood so I'm bringing a
certain sensitive sensibility to the
table that they might not necessarily
have and it's a really great experience
what can audiences expect from the score
to raid - oh it's dark it's dangerous
it's punishing it's really it really
lends a great atmosphere to the drama of
the story I think one thing that the
raid1 didn't get a lot of coverage on
was how great the story was I a lot of
people said oh it's all action but I
really felt there was a lovely story to
the raid 1 and we get more of that here
we get more of the backstory we start to
understand more of our characters and we
get introduced to a lot of great new
characters so while the fight scenes are
amazing and really up a notch for me it
was almost the dramatic hues where we
really felt that we made a really great
contribution to the raid series now you
write I mean it's a fantastic story and
there's great action there - now how
does it work for you in terms of when
you're composing for the drama as
opposed to the action yeah well we try
to relate the two because we always want
the music to come from a similar sound
world so some of the sounds we use
during the action sequences we might use
during the dramatic sequences we just
recast them a different way it's like
taking your cast of characters you know
from a fight scene and
and putting them into a dramatic scene
we take our sounds and our melodies and
our ideas and instruments and recast
them into a different mode so it's
really fun to find that through line
that narrative line just like there's a
narrative line with this story we try to
build a narrative line to the score
about fight scenes you know we've got
some tremendous ones going over the
movie for example we've seen a fight
scene in the merge get everyone getting
completely cake that it's really in all
sorts and also we've got a fantastic car
chase as well we know it's Garrett's
first car chase how is it working on
those it's really incredible specific
car chase is one of my favorite moments
of the film I hope Garret I think Gareth
really liked it like working on that too
as a director was his first car chase
and to be able to work with all that
heavy metal and do some destruction but
you know when approaching those scenes
it can be very intimidating because
they've cut to a certain rhythm and all
the choreography especially the fight
scenes is done well in advance before
they start shooting eco and Yan are
choreographing us along with Gareth
choreographing each fight scenes so by
the time we get them they already have a
really great internal rhythm so what I
find it's great what what I find is the
best way to approach these scenes is to
watch them a few times in a row without
music maybe even without sound to really
understand the rhythm that the actors
are in so that I can then kind of tune
into that rhythm and then we can match
that with the music and of course we
know we've got more aid to come yeah you
can't wait for ray to and r83 there's as
well how likely are we to see you back
scouring that one well I'm a big fan of
bold artistic dering dering artistic
movies so each raid movie has been
exactly that something that that we
could really feel free to go you know
above and beyond with and I don't see
any reason that the raid 3 won't be the
same more of the same I'm really excited
would you like to see happen in an ideal
world if you could kind of wisp into
Garen steer and say I want Rama to take
a nice bubble bath maybe give him a
massage have him see his family a little
bit spend a few months with his kid you
know chill out a little bit and then
maybe someone else gets involved no but
I I met Roy Eco and Yan for the first
time time last night they're great
people I can't wait to work with him
again
what's it like meeting them the first
time after you've seen them in so much
action and drama on screen I think it's
the same for both of us like we all were
all of us we respect each other greatly
and I've they've heard about me for a
while I've heard about them and we've
all been working together yet I've never
met so when we meet it's just a lot of
mutual respect and we're just curious
about each other how we act in real life
and it's fun now we've got another movie
coming with Gareth and also Timo who's
been here with his movie killers coming
up called the night comes for us might
you be involved in that at all I'm not
sure I really love teemo's work and I
saw killers last night at the premiere
it was fantastic and so we'll see what
happens we look forward to next we need
Joe you'll see a film from relativity
called earth to echo it's a very
Spielberg Ian movie and the style of the
Goonies it's really interesting I've
really enjoyed working on it and you'll
see some new territory that I've never
worked in before is coming up so this
coming up later this year I'm very
excited kind of Stephanie teased us this
new territory I can't know but it's it's
something I've been wanting to do for a
long time I have a few things coming up
that are in different genres and
different in different realms of music
so it's really exciting for me to be
able to stretch out from beyond my dark
cramped studio and really do something
outside of it look forward to that I'm
sure the right to fantastic as well
thanks so much for talking to us Joe
thank you
you